expert search and rescue operation is
now underway in the North Atlantic this
morning after a mini sub disappeared on
its way to the wreck of the Titanic it's
operated by the U.S based company called
Ocean Gate Expeditions now we know that
five people were on board but so far
we've only been able to identify three
of them they are British explore Hamish
Harding Pakistani businessman that's
shasada de rude and dawood's son his
name is Suleiman the search for the
vessel is underway around 900 miles east
of Cape Cod near where the Titanic sank
and where the water reaches around 13
000 feet deep the Coast Guard here in
Boston says the sub lost contact on
Sunday about an hour and 45 minutes into
its dive